I don't know I'm like I don't like doing
I'm like I'm gonna do assurance today I
I'm break down it how much do you bet
your childhood experience me something
happened you were young it has to do
with your life
my neck responsibilities
did have a lot to do today oh my god
does it yes it does
I am originally from Monterey California
all right yeah I was born in Carmel
raised in Monterey
I bet I moved around a bit down here
he's over your toe few things a few
things got me down here and one of them
was drugs and the other was not having
nowhere to stay
and I got an ex boyfriend let's go down
here so I came out here I supposed to
come down here to bid to visit and using
at me you do the little program thing
and you know go to mission I was drug
free for a year so I was clean for a
year and I ran into into a cousin
through marriage which I'm now divorced
and ended up right back in the same same
situation yeah it's an addiction to
serving your shopping okay watch out
I already talked about it but it's
neither gonna start me
I want to say my my upbringing was was
was good up until my dad got back from
Vietnam
my dad is a military mom she was working
for shield for the civil service which
is secretary for the military when he
came back I assume now I know now
around that time was era where there was
what they were doing bits and stuff like
that she shooting up and that's what he
was doing
and most of all that he was abusive so
he would you know coming in and beat him
and then he would come and harass me my
sister he would reservation yeah me oh
you
yes I was probably exactly sure what I
was liking the third fourth grade
he would he would he would he would
touch touch field
he never penetrated but at the same time
he's the grinding and I although stuff
and if I do what he but you know the but
it's anything or if I didn't agree he
would threatened to spank me know how
long was worked by machine she worked in
she worked every day worked hard you
know
like I said I really didn't know I
couldn't say anything cuz he was like
the monster he was like he was he was a
monster he was he really was I mean I
witnessed all kind of other things and
I'm not going around the kind of kitchen
needles you know I walked in the packed
in the bathroom one time and there was a
dead man you know in our tub but the
needle still in his arm tie still around
his arm I'll never feel I was nervous
but stuff I see that not talking about
that I suppose like it was yesterday
I mean cuz it's so vivid it's like it's
right there and I remarried
I remember mom going crazy no going but
this thing he slaps her feature of it
meaning he goes just a friend and he
like you take the body and my mom like
nice things
my mom's never we've never been on up
there anything so he took me to pick the
right here wrapped it up in there we
call those like that the carpets they're
really expensive they're like where they
come probably that call but I said it's
a carpet and he rolled him up the carpet
and thrown a duster like he was yeah yes
I witnessed all of this inning and after
that it was like he he would disappear
but that would disappear for today that
was hard you know
the last thing I remember like that was
we came and he beat belong so bad that
my eyes were shut she broke your ribs
she was hospitalized for about a blood
oh yeah I was I probably thought we was
gonna lose her it was scary it was
really really scary he took all that he
could as anything he could sell
he left us with no food he he would take
my mom's car I saw the car you know what
that was that was about how I see my dad
was when he beat her like that but that
never I never saw my mom my mom still
you know still stay strong and then
after that I took about a year to that
today I would less it again my cousin my
cousin on my dad's side you know like
then I was I was at least 12 13 still
yeah yeah still young but
everything you know I just like I don't
know what what it was but I know I had
to for everything like just way back
here everything was okay because my mom
made sure that we had everything we need
everything anything we needed food and
anything that we needed she she made
sure we had and
you know things started getting a little
bit better and started changing when she
went and got another job and that's why
she went to the Academy for the
Department of Corrections so does she
start work for the department questions
things changed drastically I mean we we
were living in the projects we moved out
of the projects I mean it was like we
had everything that we ever we never
wanted me and my sister and then she got
a new boyfriend
then she started doing crack back then
it was called a freemason
so see what she started freebasing it's
like everything went right back to the
way you used to be it's just that my dad
wasn't there and it was her get hot
buddies you know I almost almost painted
like where I was I was killed one of
them and
[Music]
it takes a while I didn't look but you
know I had just all talk to cocked and
ready to go
no because he was in their heart hurting
he was in the room hurting my mom but
they he wanted her to do things very
dope and all arms are crying and begging
and pleading did by this time I'm with
I'm like 16 you know we're living we're
living at Fairfield because she was
working at back of your prison and
that's when that's when I started a lot
of trouble
[Music]
I've gotten I got arrested for
shoplifting I got arrested for what is
that called a assault and battery we
would have been weapon but with the
weapon I had got expelled from school
and from there I got kicked out of the
state of California I was AI got you got
a snake elaphe way for a year I could
not come back to California for a whole
year I was awarded a court I was I was I
was declared a minister Society of
myself I went to a group all United a
whole bunch of stuff all just their
dangers just way back I mean I was I was
bad I was fired
I'm still a teenager I did all this
between ages of 15 and 17
in a 17
and I was I was bad I was I was just
close to one to ye and that was when I
thought ye see why it's a it's a it's
like a mini frozen drink of her kids and
instead of it to be in juvenile I was
something bigger my prison and I was I
was real close to going there and
I just hit me my mom well mom gave up
all right parental rights that's that's
why they keep me on the state of
California mood Arizona everything's all
right there but then I came back and
when I came back I started drinking I
was I started drinking I started we
smoke so I started smoking I started
taking acid okay
so it's true I was doing just way way
too much and during all that I got raped
and yes we didn't right I got pregnant I
didn't know I was pregnant my body body
was normal everything was still the same
you know I miss to everything they're
doing is right no sickness on that 95 I
was praying it till I was like six now
seven months yeah
and I had no stomach I'll stop still
flat I don't know fluttering I've none
of that none that done that stuff none
of things that I should have felt I
never felt and when I found if I was
pregnant mom disowned me she put me out
she had nowhere to go you know what I
was gonna do
so it we gave him I play see how they
both got any tell me and it was it was
it was sad it was really sad I was
homeless leave it outside
like that and I don't know what happened
but I guess you had a change of heart in
one day her and my sister was out
looking for me Jada got me and I was
back at home I had my daughter I thought
my daughter she took over I just took
over go right back to the same thing
doing the drugs this time I was
introduced to crack and that's when
pillows started free months
hoo-whee when I started folks for the
Primo's oh that's when I really got into
the drug scene that's what he just feels
is a tobacco and smashdown
crap national crackdown you lace it you
relates the tobacco with that you rolled
it up and I was smoking those I it was
like I could I couldn't wait to like get
away from mom we were living in sassoon
a design and I couldn't wait I turned 18
and then I turned 18 I kind of thought
it air and I need to Sacramento I was
probably one of the worst things I could
have ever done in my life but
and that it stopped me because about
Garrett's after we know I
I like it basically do ever I wouldn't
do it Venus picked up dinner and all
this stuff so I started selling drugs I
I would have to like they're the main
supplier you know he he would come over
he show me I cook I mean it was like it
was like it was like yeah I'm like
myself is rich but it felt like I was
rich
cuz I you know back then and they you
know get the food stamps in the
footsteps respect for him and I mean I
would have a drawer full of food stamps
and you know I would come down once a
month not grabbing give all her talk all
the food stamps I always have always had
money and I was never broke I just tell
I thought I was I thought I was a [ __ ]
you know I really did I thought I was a
shitty then I get to smoke with Oakland
I want to I'm here also got apartment
you know I'm like all my bills are paid
you know I never you know and I had a
drawer full of money orders so whenever
I think it'd be like it was boy grab
like I mean it was it was lovely but I
ended up
dealing with both sides of the of the
gangs of the you know of the games and
and I was dealing with a blood and and
then I the met a crypt and I didn't know
I knew what I didn't know I figured
because I thought I was you know the
[ __ ] and everything that I could I
didn't you know play around both of them
in and the guy that I'd the Crypt that
guy that I had met he stayed around the
corner and I got to know him better and
he started coming around coming around
more then he he already knew but he
tried to act like he didn't know that I
was my main supplier my guy that I
worked for was a blood yeah
long story short eventually what
happened is that he said Parata really
arrived
and didn't I Sooey didn't plan out the
way it's supposed to because I was in
what they call a cocaine coma but just
your up four days and then you go to
sleep you're dead to the world
you don't hear nothing you don't feel
that time you're just good kids you're
gone and they couldn't get in the house
I live in an apartment and they can get
in so what they did is they shot they
shot my partner they filled it with
boots I mean yes the gangbangers live
they wanted they were coming to rock but
yeah but I like it too so sleep they
knocked whatever they wouldn't able to
get yourself they would took upon myself
to shoot up sort of my apartment and a
when I said he shot my apartment they
blew out all my windows they they I was
told they use the 45 because they do a
tour of the hinges my front door blew it
straight off the hinges and they didn't
even come in they decided up real real I
mean I thought so I was just knocking at
my door yeah so I jumped up I jumped up
and as I'm walking to the door so I'm
walking to the door here to drop this
around I can do they do it like I said
they blow all the windows doors can't
rock Angelz
I mean bullets just flying everywhere
I'm like cover like glasses because I
the way I apartment was is that you
coming in and there was window right
here from there
then there was a window right there but
the living room had two windows you know
the kitchen window and he could go
around this way I'm better when we look
in the bathroom they were still holding
at all when the police finally have now
seen the way the police finally do come
the bullet there was bullets been lost
in in the wall there was one bullet that
went through my wall to my closet to my
closet in my bedroom to some clothes do
the wall through the neighbors wall
landed like two inches from the guys
here damn that was all the wall that
right there is that right there is way
made me go to the pipe that's what I was
introduced myself to the fight I was
like oh this this Primo's not gonna do
it I got scared I didn't wanna go home
and I went to friends a customer's house
coming buy drugs for me and I told her
they set me up
give me a pipe oh and pike this is not
working isn't our case you did that and
I've been smoking I was [ __ ] by
smoking crack since the age of 19 all
the way up to early last year
I could say now I am
loving much clean oh crap
yeah I know smoke crack me more but in
the meantime you know
that that that transition is smoking
crack I've been through so so much
that
I never I never I would have never
thought that crack had anything to do
with all the issues and problems that I
had and children now now I see that
everything that I went through in my
life just cause I quit that crack and
and I wanted everything so easy you know
I'm not slow not dumb I'm straight-a
student and school all the way up to
12th grade A student
like I said well I started when I was
introduced to the pre what was that
right there is like you know cuz that's
when I dropped out of school I didn't I
didn't graduate what I didn't get my GED
that's what I ain't know getting
pregnant all that stuff happened but I
never nobody could tell you that drugs
had anything to do with that I just I
was just - sorry
do that you know to all that I had a
dream after the little shooting so I had
a dreamy officer I can't do this you're
gonna kill me doing this I wanted to be
a meal which is there's no one who
transports trucks well okay yeah I can
make more money doing that you know as
well and I want everything so I want
everything easy I want everything to
come easy to me they wanted I knew I
mean I was I wasn't telling I was fine I
could get a job like you know whatever
but I didn't want to do that I just want
my money to come easy I wanted to run
the streets I want to be the party girl
and I'm gonna do all this mm-hmm and
that's it initially initially how I
ended up here in LA is transporting
drugs and I was transporting marijuana
and that's after all shootout and all
that stuff happened I was like I can't
beat out here anymore I was scared that
it would be there down there anymore and
the guy that I was going with and I
wanted to the pin and they got out he
got early release don't know how he got
out and they took him and they spotted
him behind the what is that a cyclone
state yeah they found him I'll time I'll
tidy excuse excuses now son that hit and
my mom working beyond Meyer working at
the prison there was word that you know
they were going to just come after her
you know it's girlfriend whatever and I
was a girl pretty so I'm scared so I had
to leave I don't live in Sacramento in
this that's when I start doing the
transport not here that's my way I'm
leaving got stopped now because we're
riding on the freeway three girls me and
two other girls and we are pulled over
by the fire patrol a family I don't know
well I know now this God but when they
stop this none of us went to jail
y'all got excited and we were all told
that we could not be LA County gonna
leave LA County until after go to court
so I was stuck down here in the middle
in the middle doing that what I do I run
into somebody else ain't Gucci that was
selling dope that was selling crack and
what I do I ended up selling cracking
then that's when I was introduced to
being abused
that's what I was an abusive refers
abusive relationship I was scared leave
so was i got told all my court stuff you
know when I was like when you coming
home when you come on my obvio I'll be
all but I never would come and the
reason why is good so I can go so I was
stuck there
this is it's it's after that I went it's
so funny all this time telling you no no
I've been I have been clear I've never
seen a jail cell a day my life and
listen Taylor's when I was a teenager
when I went to do it all but two holding
what I told you and your parents got to
come you - I was the furthest I got but
you know make a long story short Susie
said that I went through all that when I
was there when I when I was with the guy
Gucci I was able to get up out of that
because he ended up going to jail and I
made it run back to so soon to be a
little mom but I had to come back again
because I had another court date when it
came back that's why I met my husband
and when I met him that's what I stayed
I'm staying down here
once I this is crazy I met him at 20 we
were together for a whole 11 years from
the day that we met he took me out to
eat
we met on Thursday we went out to eat on
the Friday I never left I never left it
really moved it he was grabbed and
that's when I experienced Sherm with him
I spirit Sherm all of this stuff I went
to school I went to school Venice for
Business Administration
I went did I would school for certified
nursing assistant then I was going now
which school for medical assistant front
back office so I did all of that within
it ten to ten eleven years plus I had
another child and my daughter said of my
daughter they're seven years apart
that's the good part that's that life
right there that I'm telling you right
now there's really nothing bad that
happened here everything through that
was like living
in house with a white picket fence I
mean everything was so perfect but
but the tenth year that's when that's
when this life right here though living
right now started when the tenth year of
being in Vienna together we were smoking
a shine and he blames on the charm he
cheated with my best friend I just had
the baby and we were gone to my
grandmother's freaking everybody
pictured wedding anniversary my mom and
my sister them came back the old who I
find in my bed
goodbye is my best friend so Derek air
just the story by everything that's what
I gave up I gave up you know I am bill
my child outside our prayer parental
rights a little business side of
everything I just I don't even think I
packed a bag believe I just left
and kill my husband right tip my husband
about for my on my side I gave you sir
my second child
yeah yeah bite my kids they're two
different dads I saw know the rights and
I just I left and when I left I left to
the streets I didn't go to my mom money
gonna nobody I went straight to the
streets and that's why
that's
that's when that's when I ended up
seeing that that you know that little
sale they had for me waiting for the
instructions you know I I left feeling
and from there that all my life was just
yeah I asked you if I start crying when
my life is so it now here you go
because everything is mama my mom just
told me she would give me no more he
would never see what daughter works
that's all I got raped I just happen
yeah right never did
yeah
that's what I can say
anytime I want being but he never says I
was I was God overwhelming taking my
drugs and that's how I did it I mean I
did it what 10 tricks in body
you know I'll any opportunity I had no
they with one of my miles up the night
skills I steal things from her it's
Halloween
[Music]
I stress pain and it's usually never
trust me again
that's hurt if everything is so much
much do this I'll do that due to the age
of 30 31 I was 31 when when my left has
been I'm 31 in in January
by the end of the year I was in the year
by Christmas I had a sale in tchotchkes
well my first time
pretty good first time my first time
ever being fingerprinted arrested you
know it was happened in March in March I
was only in jail goodbye me like 32
hours and after that 32 hours the next
time I did a trip to the to a jail cell
is where
eight months
I ain't much in prison
probably drugs
because for
for this position the no sales case home
nothing else it was ills possession I
was just so the hard-headed and I was I
was defiant and I didn't feel like I had
to I feel like I can do it I do it I
want to do I don't got listening what
blah blah can't tell me what to do I do
it you know I do what I want to do um I
just I just I was when I said I was
ready to muck I ran amok and and I thank
God I know I know I thank God I tried
suicide several times it didn't work it
didn't stick years
when when I was five they feel so at me
you know thank God maybe put the gun in
my hand and click it it jammed so
they did challenge baby yeah they would
gun to my head
well it wasn't a gang it was one person
as I was selling like I said I just I
just had this thing for selling dope and
I knew that selling dope they would
support how much could be able to
support my habit and I wouldn't have to
cuz I felt real nasty when I would do
the datoria the tricks and once I got no
right so that's when I decided I never
I'm after a teen I look interest in it
at all but it I still was me it was me
yet still dressed the same way I still
act same way but sexual essentially I
didn't I wasn't interested in sex at all
I never went a mite said that's why
people say I mean I'm honest I know I
mean you know I can be real a real [ __ ]
just real just but I you know I try to
try to be a better person a nicer person
but it's really hard because
I want that sweet - nice and guys get
the wrong idea
that's why your music loud and like I'm
drowning everything around me I don't
want it I don't want to do anything I
wanna put the real world up I like I
said yeah outside play all these all
these expansion scars I got down here
I'll tell ya
yeah I've even taken a handful of pills
don't work I would sleep Oh God you know
now kneel and there's there's there's
one person
that anyone anyone I will leave that be
my daughter because she's never treated
me any differently
she's never please Olli that means she's
there for me if there's me like that's
crazy cuz Wow
I shouldn't live I should really doing
some real time really I should have well
because I believe because my mom with
the Department of Correction and and God
I just dig that one that one time you
know and the industry now you know I
mean never on the streets but I was
turning one
now I'm no crystal bezel crystal meth I
have a boyfriend I was I'm a man he's in
jail him but nobody nobody is is dare to
cross the line to even try to come at me
like that
and because of what I've been through I
can't see myself going out there and
your sexual babies for judge I have
that's what I'm saying I have and
yeah
like I can't I mean it doesn't feel good
it really doesn't feel good I feel less
than very very just just yeah I mean
that means I'm I'm telling myself that
I'm only worth drugs drugs is this all
the words no no no I I don't I just know
I can do it
I've done it and I I've said never a
million times in my life but I can
honestly say our
I understand I just don't feel it I feel
now I feel ugly abilities
horse neighs yeah I tell him I've been
too happy to sister I be too light not
still going to life